in the cult there wasn't just physical
and sexual abuse there was you know
you're talking about entire childhood of
psychological and emotional abuse as
well and for a lot of ex-members sadly a
lot turned to addictions
um and a lot of us suffer with
depression with PTSD and sadly you know
we've lost a lot of
um X sgas so my peers to suicide
thank you hi and welcome to this episode
of extraordinary lives the podcast from
love Bible I'm Ben Paul Jones and today
we're joined by Natasha Tommy Natasha
it's great to have you here thank you um
for anyone who isn't aware of who you
are would you mind giving a brief
introduction
sure so my name's Natasha Torme I'm the
author of born into a children of God
a book in which I detail my upbringing
in the notorious sect the children of
God which is now known as The Family
International
it's a cult that existed throughout the
70s 80s and still exists to this day and
in which uh there was quite a bit of
scandalous doctrines involved and which
resulted in the mistreatment of many
people including children
during the course of this conversation
we're going to talk about some
quite upsetting topics I imagine
um please do just let me know if there's
any point that you want to
pause or stop sure okay fantastic so
thanks so much for coming in today and
um I suppose let's get back to the very
beginning of your story because you were
born into the cult weren't you
yeah so the court was founded originally
in 1968 by an American Evangelical
pastor called David Berg
so he started in the U.S but it very
quickly spread into Europe and then the
rest of the world
so you had the original members who
joined most of them were very young
adults 17 18 early 20s at the start and
then as time went on they went on to
have children who we call the second
generation
adults sgas who were all born into the
cult so the big difference is that these
sga's knew nothing else about the
outside world they were really
from the their date of birth uh immersed
into this very strange lifestyle
um kind of kept in a bubble for their
childhoods
so I was born into it in the early 80s
and well remained into it until I could
legally leave at age 18.
so
it's quite an interesting story there
where you say that so David Berg the
founder he was American that's correct
yeah and then you said it quickly spread
into Europe so how how are you aware how
does something like that happen how does
somebody start a cult
somewhere in America and then for that
to be able to spread into different
areas of the globe
so already Berg felt like an outcast in
the Christian Community
his mother was a very famous Evangelical
preacher
and he thought he was going to have the
same sort of success except that he had
very um he had a bit more radical views
on Christianity and how Christians
should be living
so he was rejected very much by the
mainstream Christian groups which is
when he had the idea to start the cult
but even then he started to get a lot of
negative attention from the Press
from parents of people who had joined
the cult who had kind of gone off the
radar and
they had big concerns about what was
going on so that's when he decided Well
America is an evil Place uh you know
let's go let's go to Europe and see if
they'll accept us more there and then
the same thing kind of happened in
Europe too where before long they got
some bad press and some concerns were
raised so then it was let's go east
let's go into Asia into South America
into Africa wow so he was basically
running away from the negative press
around the globe and pretty much so it
in the cult's height
they were very very active predominantly
in Asia
South America
countries where they could get away with
things okay okay and what what
defines a cult you know what's the
difference if somebody says oh I'm gonna
just start and I'm in a small town
there's not many churches I'm going to
start practicing Christianity in a
community center with a group of people
what what's the Tipping Point when
something can be defined as a cult
um
well I think it's
the main thing is a level of control and
generally it's control of over multiple
multiple factors of a person's life so
often it will start with the control of
their finances so in the cult in our
Cults you know everyone gave up all
their money to the cult when they joined
and everything was shared no one had
their own finances so to speak
um and then there's a level of control
over lifestyle when it becomes to a
point where you're being told how to
live
of course in our cult that became very
extreme as I'm sure we'll discuss later
a control of a reproduction a control
over your working life
um I think spiritually as well
psychological control obviously comes
into play too
and when it gets to that point where the
movement is controlling the person to
such an extent that they don't have any
freedom left I think we can clearly call
that cult and then okay so to go back to
your story what are your first memories
of because because you were born into
the cult you didn't choose to join it so
I guess the beginning of your life was
that's all you knew you know what were
your first memories of it
very difficult to explain it because
that was all we knew we didn't know
anything else so for us for many years
growing up I think we just believed
everyone lived like this
we didn't really realize that we were
different and that we were being brought
up in a very strange way
um I think the older you get it's like a
slow recognition starts to come into
play where you start thinking well why
aren't we allowed to leave the house
when we want
why aren't we going to school like other
children out there
and little things like that you know
they start to add up you know why do I
feel anxious all the time why do I feel
scared
and I think in the back of your head
there's something in human nature where
you know something's wrong even at the a
very very young age but you just don't
know what it is because no one's telling
you
but so can you give us a little bit of a
snapshot of your life you know when
you're born you know which country
you're in what's your what does your
family look like at that point where are
you living like is it a compound is it a
house on a street you know just explain
to anyone who isn't aware what your life
was like at that point
so it's important to note it's like the
the frog in boiling water scenario the
cult didn't just start out with these
drastic
doctrines and things like that it was a
very slow
you know curve over time
that being said it was only over
probably a decade so not that slow so my
parents joined in France
um contraception was banned in the cult
at this time and for a long time after
that
so they had four kids very quickly four
boys and then they went on to have me
so I was born in Thailand they had just
moved to Thailand when I was born
and I was raised in several compounds so
we moved a lot in a cult again things
had changed very drastically from the
early days things were becoming quite
extreme when I was growing up
so we lived in many compounds we usually
moved every
two years or every year even
and these compounds were very big houses
usually a collection of buildings
sometimes where you could have a hundred
150 people living in it so they very
much operated a bit like a
an army camp so to speak or a boarding
school army camp a bit of the both
um in the sense that everyone lived like
one commune there was no individual
families so that's one thing Cults often
do they'll break down the family unit
because if you can't trust your own
family and you can't Unite with your own
family
all your trust is going to the leader so
so as a child were your parents clearly
your parents or was it like the other
adults in that area were also given the
task of raising you in a way yeah so you
knew who your parents were
um but everyone was your parent so all
the other adults you would call uncle
and auntie and they had as much right to
discipline you
as anyone else to tell you what to do
Etc so we were because we're so many
children about 60 to 70 percent of the
population at its height was children
wow because contraception was bad so we
were put in straight away you know put
into groups
by age range so you'd have the nursery
group you'd have the young children the
middle children the older children so
you were raised in these groups with a
teacher which was any uncle or Auntie
from that commune that was assigned to
your group so they would be with you all
day they'd often sleep with you as well
at night in the same room
so you're kind of raised in that kind of
environment where there was no like
individual family you'd see your family
only once a week on the Sunday the rest
of the time you were permanently in this
group separated from your parents
separated from your siblings and kind of
raised in this boarding school type
environment
um which you know I always say was a for
me a very very sad upbringing because we
were there were so many people around
you but you were so lonely
um so what was it that made you lonely
if you're saying you were surrounded by
a load of people and actually you had
more access to adults that were in a
sort of educational and parental role
what was making you feel lonely
well firstly you couldn't trust anyone
so you learn very quickly that you
couldn't trust the adults and you
definitely could not trust your peers so
they created this environment of
reporting on each other you know your
only loyalty was to to God Jesus the
cult leader the Shepherds of the home
that was it and your teacher of your
group so if another kid did something
wrong you had to go report on them say
what they did they'd get badly punished
for it yeah and there was just an
environment of of high anxiety and
stress and complete distrust of each
other even at very very a very young age
which is pretty sad because you know
you're separated from your siblings
they'll be in different age groups to
you than urine you're not seeing your
parents hardly ever and then you've got
that kind of environment you're in 24
hours a day
so I just remember being very anxious as
a child and why was it happening like
what was David Berg trying to achieve
why did he want to set up this cult and
create all these rules and separate the
children and make you know what was he
trying to do well it was it's all about
control so he when I was growing up was
when the doctrines were at at their
worst or most extreme I would say but he
believed that it was his job he was the
prophet of the end or reincarnation of
the Prophet Moses
and that the Colt's job was to raise an
end time Army so that's what we were wow
okay
um we were being raised to be soldiers
for God in the last seven years of the
earth which Christians call the end time
which is when the Antichrist comes in
and tries to eradicate all Christians
and kill them off
so we were being trained to to
um fulfill this great destiny
which again was a lot of pressure
growing up as a kid but we had constant
uh psychological training Doctrine
training you know a lot of reading books
Publications memorizing his words
Etc we had practical training as well
how to survive in you know forests so he
thought this would be like a genuine
sort of apocalyptic fight absolutely
yeah wow so you'd be out there
controlled you know we would be on the
Run
for at least three and a half of those
seven years and he predicted dates too
so he predicted several but I remember
one key date he had predicted was 93.
and that's when you know the Jesus was
going to come back and all that so I was
expecting to die around the age of 10 12
because we're told you know most of us
were going to be murdered as Martyrs for
God and we kind of had to just accept
that fate and was he because quite often
with these kind of people the the
the Antichrist is then used as a way of
describing types of people that already
exist on Earth was he like that or was
he actually saying like there'll be
devils and monsters reappearing that you
have to fight with
the Antichrist for him was an actual man
right who was going to take over the
world in its entirety and he was going
to exerto you know full control over
everything he was going to ban all
religions he was going to make everyone
have a chip in their forehead or their
hand you know and just have full control
over everything and it was our job to
fight him and his his armies and how
were you fighting him like like weapons
guns you know what what was the fighting
well we were supposed to get super
powers okay so there was supposed to be
a point in the end time where we would
receive superpowers from God be that you
know
we could do lightning bolts from our
fingers or throw fire through our eyes
um so where is he getting that from
verses in the Bible or is he just did he
just start to make invent things
he based a lot of his stuff on things
from the um Book of Revelations but
obviously he also received most of his
information through his gift of Prophecy
which is hearing directly from God now
of course we didn't know until much
later that he was a raging alcoholic so
okay yeah a lot of his rants were under
heavy influence of alcohol okay
okay so
um I guess let's go back to the so
you're born in Thailand and how long did
you stay there for
so we stayed in Thailand about 10 years
in many different communes we then moved
on to Malaysia for a couple of years
Indonesia for a year
and finally back to France and bounced
to Reunion Island and a bit everywhere
and where where so is he buying these
communes is he creating or is he renting
space you know where's the money coming
from to generate the ability to move
whole groups of people around the world
so there are several sources of income
depending on the period of time it was
in
at the very start uh a lot of their
income came from incoming members
because when you joined you gave
everything if you had inheritance that
inheritance went to the cult wow after
that they did a lot of selling you know
posters and things they did a lot with
music they had a in France for example
in the 70s they had a very famous dance
and singing group called lisner fondue
the children of God in French and they
were actually on TV and everything
um and they were cult members yeah wow
and they were just like a pop group
super popular yeah and even in later on
in Thailand for example
um they had a lot of very big dance
troops and stuff and some of their
singers became very famous
um they didn't always use you know the
family International they would use a
lot of other names depending on which
country they're in so with this because
at this point at the beginning it was
called the children of God right yeah
and that name had maintained through
your childhood is that right no there
was a point
um
it was probably around the time I was
born I don't know the exact date but
there was a point where they changed to
the family of love and very quickly to
the family International so again all of
this was part of the you know escaping
bad reputation yes
you know no we're not the children of
God we're not we're the family
International
right we're a completely different cult
we disbanded the children of God but it
was all the same people right okay you
know it was they were quite savvy
in that way and they became even more
Savvy with time where legally they knew
exactly how to twist things and and slip
out when you're moving around the world
like that so when you move to Thailand
are you picking up thai members or is it
like the same kind of group of people
moving around you know were you
collecting different nationalities of
people as you went yeah yeah yeah it was
a very uh multi-cultural place so we had
a lot there were quite a few Thai
Nationals who joined as well
um but from a fundraising point of view
so you had a period where a lot of the
fundraising then starts to come from
flirty fishing which is one of the most
scandalous doctrines that the cult is
most well known for
so that began again you know nothing
just happens overnight it's always small
suggestions that lead to other things
so it started off with David Berg
believing that well first he introduced
the law of love
which was a law he said anything was
permissible if it was done in love with
love
yeah you know where this is going yeah
um so first that very much affected
adults
so there was a lot of sharing they
called it that started happening so this
is over over like 10 years they went
from being quite conservative no sex
before marriage
um things like that then they said
actually it's okay for people to have
multiple wives or multiple husbands so
threesome started happening then sharing
started with the law of love
so that was the idea that to obtain full
unity in the group adults should share
their partners with other adults that
did not have a partner
so it was the idea that no one should be
frustrated in that sense out of love you
should you know let your wife go and
help out that lonely
member over there who doesn't have a
wife and they still have the no
contraception rule yep right
um but very quickly that just went to
complete extremes it was not at all
about single people anymore it was
everyone sleeping with everyone
married not married orgies were
happening sharing schedules were put up
in some homes
some homes were you know there was more
control the more radical communes which
are a lot of those in Thailand so
there'd be a schedule and the Shepherds
of the home would decide tonight you're
sharing with that person you're sharing
with that person
you know so over what a year or two it
went from conservative to you don't even
have a choice you sleep with anymore
so that that feels fast to me because to
go from a over the period of a year to
go from like
conservative Christianity to basically
the flip of what you know the way that
most sort of it may have been more than
two years but it certainly wasn't more
than but it feels like it's you know
when you look at he was American
originally and when you look at
conservative American Christians they're
very much against that yeah that way of
life and the fact that you know do you
think that was because that was
something he truly believed was the
correct thing to do or do you think it
was he it's just something he wanted to
do you know where was his
thought process coming from do you think
I think he was uh for lack of a better
word with all we know now about him he
was a sexual pervert a complete deviant
in that sense you know he used to get
prophecies and dreams about sleeping
with his own mother you know so I think
a lot of it was about control but then a
lot of it was that he was fulfilling his
own strange fantasies in some ways so
during this big sexual Revolution as I
called it you know he also requested
that woman send in Striptease videos to
him and he would write these letters
detailing exactly what he wanted them to
do you know and I don't want you to show
me everything straight away you know and
and in detailed instructions so all the
loads of women around the world and even
sadly some children
we're sending in these Dance videos to
him
this is Ben Paul Jones we're just going
to take a break from today's episode to
talk about one of our sponsors better
help this show is brought to you by
betterhelp how much time do you spend on
yourself in an average week
so easy to get caught up in what
everyone else needs from you and never
take a moment to think about what you
need from yourself but when we spend all
of our time giving it can leave us
feeling stretched thin and burned out
therapy can give you the tools to find
more balance in your life so you can
keep supporting others without leaving
yourself behind
therapy is something I've used several
times in my own life I think sometimes
we think it has to be for huge events or
massive changes but I like to just use
it every couple of months or a couple of
times a year check in on myself if
anything's feeling like a struggle book
a few sessions top myself back up
visit betterhelp.com minutes with today
to get 10 of your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash minutes with
now back to the episode
and this at this point this is still
because God wants this to happen because
this is going to help us in the fight or
is has it becomes something different oh
that that's still going on yeah whole
end time thing but this is all about
unity and and love we are a family of
Love okay so
um so then sharing
went a step further into flirty fishing
so then it you know Berg again slowly
introduced it saying oh my wife and I
Karen Zerby are doing this experiment
where at night we're going to clubs and
she's showing God's love to lonely
businessmen who are there
yeah
you know and it started with you know
just talking to them and dancing with
them and then very quickly the
experiment went further and she was
actually sleeping with them and so it
became this is really successful for us
so you know we'd like you guys to start
this too
and the purpose was to recruit people to
the cult or just to do it well at the
beginning yes it was really about
showing God's love and you know
potentially trying to recruit someone to
the cult
but you know demonstrating demonstrating
God's love in a physical way
right
um so
and then that you know was so successful
that it became means of fundraising
so it wasn't just flirty fishing it was
escorting Services called esing where
they were actually being paid as escorts
as well and expecting donations in
exchange for their time and whatever
Services they were providing and you
know you have to understand the concept
of group think to understand how you can
get to such an extreme
you know and there were people who left
along the way but the majority stayed
and if you understand the way group
think and and um uh psychological
coercion work then you understand why
all these people stayed because they
were just in that environment where if
you dare to go against it you were an
outcast
and I guess at this point I mean maybe
I'm wrong but I'm imagining that the men
weren't doing flirty fishing yes they
were they were so the majority was woman
because obviously
yes that was the more successful side of
things but yeah the men would do it too
so the doctrine at that point was that
everyone had to go out to clubs and do
their best to sleep with people in the
hope of getting a donation for the
course yeah not everyone would you know
there were some homes where they didn't
like the practice as much as others but
certainly the more active
and more dedicated communes it was uh a
big operation basically it was like a
you know every night you had your core
ffers there were esers that would go out
and they'd be accompanied by some guys
to you know for protection and
then you had the people who obviously
weren't as successful at it as at it be
it because they just didn't have the
looks for it who would stay home and
take care of things at home but they
threw FFA flirty fishing
they met a lot of powerful people as
well lawyers politicians members of the
army generals things like that
who later would go on to protect them
and you know Shield them a little bit
from
when the rumors started coming out again
and things like that in certain
countries I mean I know there were some
someone I lived with had a Arabic Prince
as well who was on her ffing schedule
who would you know just give her
handfuls of jewels God yeah and what do
you think the what was the draw to an
outsider to join a cult like that like
because what you're describing you know
if I mean it sounds awful you know it
sounds like no control over your life no
control over your finances or your home
or your family so if people are born
into it obviously you know no different
but if people are outside that looking
in and get invited to join it what's the
draw for a for an adult to see that and
go okay yeah that seems like a positive
way to live my life
well firstly they never showed that side
to the world their facade that the
public saw was so so different it was
black and white
you know to the outside we looked like
this really uh lovely group of people
who were just trying to do good for God
you know we did a lot of humanitarian
work as well
as part of our fronts so from the
outside we looked like people who were
really just there to help you know help
people were poor uh help orphanages
schools and things like that but also by
the time all the extreme doctrines came
out they already had their core
membership
okay they didn't recruit very much from
the time I was uh
a very young child I don't remember
there being many incoming new recruits
it was quite rare and if there were it
was more in places like Africa and
things like that where
you know they weren't aware of what was
maybe going on in the other more extreme
communes of the cult but then they also
didn't tell new recruits what was going
on you didn't join the cult and hey
gonna go flirty fishing tonight there
was a whole process to join the cult he
started off Babe's status where you
could only read certain documents that
were very clean called The Milk of the
word and they slowly built you up to the
meat of the word okay which was the more
heavy duty stuff and that's the frog in
the pan of hot water you described
earlier where you as you developing
being part of this going further into it
okay well let's just go back a little
bit to to one of the more
stressing aspects of that cult
um there are quite widespread reports of
child abuse within it yeah would you
mind if we talk about that a little sure
because we've had also be huge
brainwashing techniques going on but
they are adults obviously with children
who have less ability to make their own
choices is more distressing you know can
you tell us a little bit about that
aspect of the cult
sadly as part of the sexual Revolution
came also uh Berg's suggestion that
children should be able to experience
sexuality from a very very young age
um so the way children were impacted was
greatly affected by one particular book
that was published
um so you had Berg's letters that
already started a quite a wave and it
wasn't like uh pedophilia was happening
out in the open or anything
but it basically gave permission and no
rules
for anyone who was that way inclined to
go ahead and do it
and whether it was there were some homes
in which it was openly practiced so I
know there was some communes in Greece
where it was open practice everyone knew
it was happening there were other homes
like the homes in Thailand
where I lived where it was happening
maybe some people knew about it but
didn't say anything
but it was happening and some knew some
didn't it was kind of behind closed
doors
um
but there was this one particular book
that came out that was written by
a woman called Sarah Keeley and
co-written by Karen Zerby who's
currently an earth cult I'm called the
story of davidito so davidito was a
child Karen Zerby had who was born as a
result of ffing flurry fishing
um and but David Burke had kind of taken
him under his wing and adopted him as
his son and he was kind of being raised
to be the next king of the cult so to
speak and this book was all about the
different ways they were experimenting
with raising him including
you know some pretty disturbing detailed
accounts and photographs of him being
sexually molested when he was a toddler
from the age of one two
and onwards so when that book came out I
mean
there are some adults in the cult who
say they never took it as an instruction
to abuse they took it as a a Doctrine
experiment and there are others in the
cult who really took it as
this is what we're gonna do now
so unfortunately you know
because children don't always talk when
they're abused it wasn't until quite a
bit later that
I think we realized there was a lot more
sexual abuse that happened than anyone
could have imagined and it was known at
the time because there was a point where
they had to put their foot down say stop
because I think there were some
instances where very young girls got
pregnant
then also came AIDS and sexually
transmitted diseases so flirty fishing
had to stop and then further down the
line they kind of said okay we need to
stop we need to ban shot uh any type of
interaction with children
um because of all you know it was
starting to get out there was starting
to be rumors and stuff
um but before that it was very much it
just went on and after that it went on
as well where they would issue a you
know an official letter saying anyone
who does this is touches children is
going to be excommunicated and then just
behind that would come a bar letter Burn
After Reading
guys we've had to say this and this
happened all the time in the cold we've
had to issue this you know
because the world doesn't understand our
doctrines they don't understand what
we're trying to do
so yes we need to stop doing it but just
to let you know that we stand behind our
doctrines you know and we still believe
there's nothing wrong with things I've
done love so you know the mixed
messaging so they'd send a letter like
that and then the the adults would read
it and then destroy it so that there
wasn't evidence that they'd said yeah
discard that previous one and there were
so many documents that were destroyed
um luckily some ex-members actually
stole a trunk of them that hadn't been
destroyed yet and that's all the
evidence that's online now without that
we would have no evidence really and
what what happened to the boy that was
being raised by the two cult Founders oh
that was extremely sad so davidito who
um later was known as Ricky Rodriguez
um he went against his mother at some
point after his father died his mother
took over
um even though he's being raised to be
the next leader he you know he started
traveling and listening to okay his
peers and finding out all the abuse they
went through as well he went through
terrible abuse too
um
and he tried to rebuild his life in the
outside world but he just didn't manage
to get there he was so haunted by
everything that happened to him and he
felt some kind of responsibility
because of his position in the cult and
he spent some time looking for his
mother because he wanted to kill her
and instead she was she's been living in
hiding for decades
and instead he found one of his nannies
one of the ones in the infamous book
who abused him and he killed her and
then killed himself
it was absolutely tragic but it was also
a huge
event that caused a lot of the younger
generation to leave because then we
thought nah
if this is the the child of the cult
leader
you know and things were so bad for him
you know
this was just crazy we need to go
and I I um do you mind me asking you
about your experiences because I know
you had sure
um deeply unpleasant experiences uh
along the lines of what we've been
discussing
yeah sure so I was uh sexually abused at
the age of four
multiple occasions over about a year
um
yeah it was uh someone who was assigned
one of the uncles who was assigned to
take care of my group children
you know these were people who had
absolutely no child care experience and
you know it was considered a lowly job
as well all the super smart super
popular people were the fundraisers and
things like that so it was kind of all
the
all the Riff Raff were put on child duty
um but yeah he was a Filipino
member of the cult who
took advantage of this position really
and I know that he did it to another
girl at least one other girl
and my father actually excommunicated
him a few years later because he found
out about the other girl I didn't say
anything until I was about 10.
I don't know why I just felt so
dirty hmm
it's just you just didn't feel like you
could trust anyone enough to tell as
well because you could see sometimes
someone would say something about
someone touching them and then they go
and get their mouth washed out with soap
or they'd be put on silence restriction
for a week
you know you were punished and called
Liars all the time so it must have been
confusing too because from what it
sounds like there was actually mixed
messages whether it was actually a bad
thing anyway
so as in when the people well that's it
and that was the main thing is that you
didn't know was bad no one ever told you
it isn't until much later it's not okay
for someone to touch you in that way or
to do that to you you know so you had no
idea you were being told by this abuser
that he was showing you God's love but
at the same time you felt so sick to the
stomach when it was happening and so
just horrible and scared and disgusted
it was very very confusing especially
when you're that young you know at age
four you just don't have the mental
capacity to deal with a situation like
that
um
so did he did did your abuser remain in
the cult for several years with you yeah
yeah until your father well thankfully
he was only in charge of our group for
one year okay so that put an end to it
at least at some point
but then yeah my father found out he was
he had done something to another girl
and he excommunicated him but then you
know it happened all the time people
were excommunicated and then you'd go to
another commune and there they'd be oh
really they were left back in because
they'd repented oh
that happened a lot as well
I I mean
you said that you became aware that
something felt wrong about the cult you
know like you say you'd grown up there
you'd been raised in it
um you're progressing through life
that's all you're told and you as you
said earlier that you're told that
everyone else doesn't understand the
other Christians don't understand
they've turned away from the true word
of God what was the point in your life
where you started to feel like something
might not be
everything that you've been told
oh much later I think it was only
um because the cult started having some
legal issues
around 93 94 just after
just around the time Berg died
um so they had there were raids that
took place because there had been
reports in several countries that
there was a lot of child abuse going on
in this cult
so their homes were raided by police and
Social Services in certain countries it
was like a simultaneous
raid across the world oh wow yeah so
like they'd all sort of community I
believe so because it was all around the
same time so there must have been some
kind of uh coordination going on
um so some homes in South America
Australia France
um not in Thailand now
um yeah I think that was it England
maybe as well
and that led to there was a big court
case going on at the same time in
England with a custom it started as a
custody court case
um there was a grandmother who was
trying to get custody of her grandchild
who was being raised in a cult but it
turned into the cult being on trial
so all of this media attention was
happening so they had to clean up their
act at some point and they had to stop
being so obvious and so you know
standing out so much so they ordered all
the big communes to break down into
smaller units and the Spurs type thing
um
so when we ended up in a smaller unit we
then moved back to France it was kind of
just my family it's the first time
we were alone as a family with just one
or two other members passing through
sometimes
so we started to have a little bit more
access to the outside world because
growing up you know these big compounds
you never left the compound unless it
was to go fundraise or to go renew your
Visa or for something specific you know
you couldn't just interact with
Outsiders right never happened you were
always being watched being you know told
what to say and things like that
so when we started being
able to actually talk to Outsiders is
when you know we started to realize I
was a young teenager by then
this is
the way we live is just really weird let
me ask you a question there then
um just get a bit of detail can you
explain
how you lived what was the day today in
Nicole you know why was it weird why was
it different to what somebody that was
raised in France as an average teenager
my experience already it was sort of
military Camp lifestyle
so you didn't leave the cult you had
your group you were had school in your
group all of our schooling was cult
created we had no access to outside
music
books films there were a handful of
those that we could access but they had
been chosen by the cult because they fit
the Cults doctrines so you know on
movies for example would be uh The Sound
of Music right Jesus of Nazareth
um and biblical stories and things like
that but they were very very very few
things that we could access everything
because they were very successful in
creating their own content as well they
actually started media companies
and created videos for children music
videos for children they created all
sorts of you know
um music tapes and videos and books
which they sold to Outsiders as well
under different names of course Aurora
Productions right you know so it didn't
say it was specifically from the cult
and that was a big way they made money
for a long time as well and through
their subsequent magazines too which
they still do now
um so you kind of had this complete
bubble
you know everyone came in and out
it was everything was controlled there
was no access to anything and day to day
was regimented on on the minute you know
you single fall marched to your
classroom for school time oh wow um
single foul to the canteen you know the
big room with all the tables because
there were so many people it was like
and when you when you're going to the
classroom for school time are you doing
are you studying maths English biology
or is it you know what kind of you had
the three R's so Reading Writing
arithmetics
that was pretty much it they taught
science as in their own version of
science you know the biblical
they taught history in their way too you
know their version of history or Bergs
so was that like how you know when you
say their science was it no Evolution no
dinosaurs
yeah the Earth is only 4 000 years old
right okay that's that's science yes so
there was no curriculum so to speak it
was really you were studying what Berg
had written in letters over over the
years I mean he wrote thousands upon
thousands of letters
over the time he was leader on every
topic imaginable from day to day you
know Ever every aspect of day-to-day
life down to how many pieces of toilet
paper you could use
oh yeah that detailed to how to raise
your kids obviously to you know what
kind of diet you should have what kind
of exercise you should be doing it's
really really uh
regiment and is that because he he is he
saying because I'm just trying to
understand you know why you if someone
tells you how many pieces of toilet
paper to use is it because he's saying
God's told me that that's correct or is
it at this point is he just a
charismatic leader of the people and
they just think well he's yes well he
was the father of the people so every
ass he you know it was really like I
care so much about you I want to make
sure you're really living the way we
should be living according to God's
standards and the toilet paper one is
one that comes up often because it's so
ludicrous
um but that was really about waste you
know he hated waste so he thought you
know you could take three pieces of
toilet paper and use it for seven
different things before he threw it away
yeah oh my god um but yeah it was really
that controlled and how would because he
as a leader he must have been
sort of charismatic you know did you did
you ever meet him no very few people met
him oh really so he wasn't standing here
from the beginning when he left the
states it became his core leadership
Circle
and they went into hiding and that was
it we didn't even see a photo of him
until after his death it was always a
cartoon depiction of his face wow and
then so he'd just be sending these
letters out to everyone communes but you
weren't you know he well this is one of
the most incredible things about Berg I
not 100 sure but I think he is the only
cult leader who has ever managed to do
that to successfully maintain such a
high level of control yeah over you know
10 to 15 000 people without them ever
meeting him without them ever being in
his presence he was that charismatic
through his words and he had that level
of control through his leadership team
so he he was he lived in hiding for
the majority of his life yeah because
when we've been talking so far I
imagined that it was him moving to
Thailand and saying right we're moving
here now setting it up then him no no we
were everywhere across the globe even in
the west which was evil he still
maintained smaller communes there we
were absolutely in every continent and
that was his aim was to be
you know International
hey this is Ben Powell Jones we're just
taking a brief break so I can tell you
about one of our sponsors a brand new
six-part podcast from message herd and
podimo who robs A banks he follows
journalist Jake Warren as he sets out to
explore the Stranger Than Fiction tale
of the man who kidnapped a Banksy statue
from the middle of Central London in
broad daylight and held it to Ransom the
ACT would lead to an almost 20-year war
of bad blood relations and legal battles
that are still been waged today and it
all comes down to one man and one
Vendetta but it doesn't end there the
story will take us on a journey through
UK's most subversive subcultures from
art heists and art terrorists to 80s
football hooliganism and the 90s illegal
Rave scene even fetish parties and
throughout it all Jake will be trying to
get a hold of the most Elusive and famed
Anonymous artists in the world in the
new six-part series host Jake Warren
speaks to Tiger King of the art scene
Andy link and those closest to Banksy
himself exposing their two decade-long
Feud and attempting to track down the
world's most elusive Anonymous artist
who robs a Banksy is available now
wherever you get podcasts to hear the
whole series ad free subscribe to
Pottermore UK on Apple podcasts now back
to our episode
so when you see when you see
documentaries on Cults and the
brainwashing that goes on with the
people that join them or that are born
into them it's usually by a couple of
people who are very good at that but
it's usually face to face or mass groups
so how was he able to do you mind the
term brainwashing is that an okay term
to use that's fine yeah
um how is he able to brainwash adults
without any like how when when adults
were joining how how was the cult able
to you know we spoke earlier about the
gradual slope into it but I'm just
trying to put myself in this position
how would they
persuade me
that my lifestyle was evil I was doing
the wrong thing if I joined that call
I'd be guaranteed you know a place in
heaven or whatever it was like what were
the techniques they used if he wasn't
there face to face
well they were very good at recruiting
firstly everyone became very good at
recruiting they created this kind of on
fire excitement in people and they were
very very persuasive but he led through
his leadership team which he changed
often to make sure no one got too
powerful wow there was a point in in the
height of the craziness where he just
went every all you leaders are demoted
I'm putting a whole new structure into
place and they regularly restructured to
make sure you know
that's crazy
there wasn't even a group of people that
were constant leaders it was it was some
yes at the higher level so you had you
know his wife Karen Zerby Peter uh Peter
Kelly who's now her husband her second
husband so you had some core people at
the top that remained pretty constant
but and he had his his team around him
you know quite a few followers who were
there
um
running his show and then he had his
World Service offices which would
produce all the material
You Know audio visual material and then
he had well they called them different
names over the years as they
restructured but he had his
his well the latest term would have been
visiting servants so they were people
who were in touch with some of the
higher up people
and they would go out
and visit all the communes very
regularly
to make sure things were going as they
were supposed to the people were lit
were
following Berg's instructions and these
local leaders as we can call them you
know they were really worshiped as well
you know they were seen as wow and were
they friendly kind people were they
intimidating presence when they arrived
to check up oh both right you know
they would put that lovely smile on and
I am a servant of God but
there was a a great Authority
over people a control over people and
you know
it's very simple you don't like what's
going on here
get out and would there ever you
mentioned earlier about uh Mouse being
washed out were there ever punishments
for people who weren't behaving in the
correct way
well for the adults so as part of the
control you have to remember due to
contraception families were big most
people had my parents ended up with
12 kids in the end and that that's not
uncommon in the cult but um wow by this
stage as I was growing up you know most
families were eight nine ten people
ready
um and you were usually living in a
foreign country
so some homes would take a
take the passport some home was wouldn't
so that wasn't necessarily a mean to
control but even if you wanted to leave
what are you going to do you've got this
massive family you've got no access to
significant finances certainly not
enough to fly 10 children and a wife
back to Mainland Europe
you know let alone what are you going to
do when you get to Europe you've never
had an official job you've never
contributed to a pension
or any social thing you know you were
completely and utterly trapped and what
was your option if you started to
complain
go
but your spouse and your children are
staying oh I see so that's you know
going back to why you destroy the family
unit because then the wife would be like
I can't give up serving God you know if
that's what you want then you leave but
I'm staying with the children and then
the guy would be like well obviously I
have no choice then and it will work the
other way around too I guess at that
point they've disconnected from their
their parents as well of course you know
you're isolated you haven't spoken to
your parents in 20 years of course there
are situations where you know people got
in touch with their parents and got
rescued you know there was one situation
in Thailand where a man had stayed with
the children and the woman went back
home
I think she was from the U.S and came
back and kidnapped her children from the
cold it's a there's a documentary about
it online it's quite interesting
um but that was rare most of the times
it was either you stay and you shut up
or you go and you lose your family so
there wasn't a threat of violence or
those kind of punishments it was it was
much more psychological than that the
control methods yeah the children of
course there was a lot of violence
towards us
or what like corporal punishment yeah oh
really well they strongly believed in
spare the rod spoil the child oh right
okay so there was a lot of very harsh
physical discipline you know even later
on when
the first group of children were
becoming pre-teens and teenagers they
were starting to maybe show some signs
of rebellions they set up teen training
camps as they called them
where they got all these teenagers
together
um it's you know put extra effort into
making sure that they were staying on
the right path that the court wanted
them to so they would go through hours
and I never went to one my older brother
did it was hours and hours of being read
Birds doctrines every day
physical work work to you know make sure
you were good and tired so you're more
receptive
in some cases like in McCall I believe
in the Philippines and in Japan
we now know there were literal forms of
torture going on
horrendous from isolation to
you know the silence restriction but to
extreme levels where you couldn't speak
for a month
to anyone and yet to walk around with a
sign around your neck saying I am on
silence restriction don't speak to me
you know there were forms of physical
beatings and exorcisms that took place
that were
just completely beyond the realm of
Corporal punishments
and that was in the more extreme
camps detention camps some of them were
cold
but in the average home I mean physical
discipline just became part of your
daily life really right
okay
there's a lot to take in you know
there's I mean every time you we go into
a new area of it the things you
tell us are just
sort of more and more horrifying
when you mentioned earlier about Berg
and the fact that he was in hiding for
years ultimately as soon as he left
America him and his wife and the went
into went into hiding was he rich like
was he in hiding in a mansion somewhere
with servants or was he in hiding as we
think of you know
terrorist leaders in hiding moving
around from you know a bit of both
because there was a point where he was
looked for by Interpol he was on their
Wanted list for prostitution because of
flirty fishing okay
um and when you've just said that that's
so true as in I was listening to flirty
fishing going
oh wow that's a weird thing the cult did
but it was just prostitution wasn't it I
always like to call it what it is
religious prostitution yeah it's that
simple except the poor woman weren't
even allowed to keep the money yeah so
but he he
um
he traveled under fake IDs fake
passports him and his surrounding they
moved a lot country to Country to make
sure
no one could really ever figure out
where they were only his court very very
core Circle ever knew where he was or
what name he was operating under but at
the same time he also lived a life of
luxury because every home would give
um I believe it was about 14 of their
income every month
later tithe kind of thing yes that was
tithe exactly
um and that would apparently go towards
the running costs of the whole
leadership team and all that but I mean
we know he always lived in houses with
lovely pools had access to the best food
and
as for Servants of course that was just
the cult members that was their job so
okay so when you I want to get the order
right actually so
when you'd move back to France and
you're talking about the time when you'd
move back just with your family was he
still alive at this point no no so what
so did he die while he was still in
Thailand
we were in Malaysia when he died okay
and you were what age
I would have been just 10 10. so quite
often in these circumstances I think
when the central leader of occult not
always but if they die or pass away all
the arrested or something it's very hard
to maintain it and keep it going and
keep the cohesive whole so how was that
presented like him dying before the
prophecies had been realized that he
said 1990s he was talking about the
Antichrist coming back and stuff how did
they manage to keep the cult
together and running as they wanted it
to and who took over from him so his
wife Karen Zorb took over there was a
whole series of letters that came out
where Berg had passed the mantle on to
her she was the chosen one to to pick up
the mantle and become the next leader
um but I think essentially if you look
at their entire history
things kind of went downhill after his
death and okay so she did manage to
maintain control mainly through bringing
out a lot of her own
Innovative doctrines and things and you
know trying to she tried to to Really uh
say hey I'm not Berg you know excite the
younger generation of things and was she
getting messages from God yet so now she
was the yes and how many people were in
the culture at this point at its height
at its height about 10 to 15
000. God all all in all 30 people 30 000
people have passed through the group
approximately okay huge at any one time
at a time it was about ten to fifteen
thousand okay again about 70 were
children okay a massive population of
Second Generation and so she's now
saying you know I've got a new way of
doing it God's now showing me the new
more I don't know what was it what was
the difference when you said she wanted
to put her own stamp on it what was
different well she tried to focus she
tried to eradicate a lot of
um the practices that Berg had brought
in that she knew because around the time
he died there was a lot of attention
from authorities in the media and she
knew that in order for the cult to
survive they would have to kind of um
turn their back a little bit on Berg but
again so what they had to do for example
for the UK court case
it was essentially the cult was on trial
they brought in all sorts of witnesses
who talked about abuse said lived
through and things like that and the
judge ultimately he wasn't
um the court case was not about the cult
officially so he couldn't do anything
about that it was about custody but he
did say in his ruling which is hundreds
of pages long and very interesting that
he did find that there was systematic
abuse across the cult and that it was
institutionalized so the cult in order
to win the custody case
they had to write to the judge
renouncing all of Berg's doctrines on
child sex and all that which they did to
win the case the custody case for
children that were in the for a child a
child it was a one custody case that
turned into the whole cult being on
trial in the UK okay so they did that
letter just to be able to get custody of
that kid as a court so the cult want or
was it the parent of the child that was
trying to get the kid back
or was it the grandmother was trying to
get the kid out right okay cult spent
Millions fighting the case to keep the
child because it became the cult okay
okay sort of on trial
um so they were forced to renounce
Berg's Doctrine on that and of course
right behind that Zerby then published
another letter to her followers saying
we only had to say that to win the case
you know all that again you have to
remember that Karen Zerby even when Berg
was alive was extremely powerful in the
cult so like I said he was an alcoholic
for many many years
and she was really the one running the
show most of the time she's the one who
wrote the story of davidito she's the
one who would take down his words
was heavily involved in the final drafts
that would be sent out
but then over time after Berg's death
she kind of tried to imply that
everything was Berg
that you know that's that's the big
issue we have now is that no one's
looking at Karen Zerby
when she was so so involved in
everything that happened but you were
saying earlier that she is still on the
run as well right she's in hiding is
that is that that's right we know she
her last
name change legally was Catherine Smith
but we have no idea where she is
anywhere in the world rumored around
Mexico somewhere but
so okay so you have moved back with your
family to France there's more access to
the outside world you're now how old
sorry
um that point of time I was about 13 13
okay so is this the point in time you
start to realize
something's up you know the outside
world is is not as horrible as you might
have thought or absolutely yes that was
the first uh big shocker
for me was you know these systemites as
we called them you know they were seemed
to be really nice people they didn't
seem to be evil at all or scary or you
know and just generally the way the
outside world seemed to function
um
just didn't seem wrong to me and then
more and more the way we were
functioning seemed wrong to me
and that was around that time in the
cold a lot of SGA started leaving second
Generations
it started with a small handful who left
who were heavily criticized by the cult
leader of course we were they were
called demons and you know we're always
told that really bad things would happen
to us if we left the coach and we all
become drug addicts and die and get
murdered and all sorts of things so
there was a huge fear about leaving but
luckily once the first batch left
it just kind of started a role as kids
were becoming of age
they were starting to leave and more and
more and more left until
uh the pretty much the majority of sgas
left the cult in the end wow over time
because of course each you know you had
to get to an age where you could legally
leave and be independent and was that 16
or 18 18 18. what I guess it depends on
which country you're in
certainly in France it was 18 yeah so
was there a point was there a specific
point in time you sat down with your
family and said look I'm going to leave
yes
yes already left right so the worst was
when you were the first of the family to
do it yeah
um but I had some who had already left
so it wasn't as difficult but then
it was horrible in a way because you
knew that you were causing the greatest
disappointment you ever could to your
parents who really believed that that
was the life that you were chosen for
that was your your ultimate mission in
life was to to grow to be this this
person in the end time
um so yeah it was difficult having that
conversation and even more difficult
after you left because you were treated
like a backslider or traitor of some
sort so can you talk us through what it
was like to leave you know what did that
look like was it a slow process or were
you suddenly this is how I've lived my
life and now the whole world's opened up
to me and I'm living in a flat somewhere
you know what what did it actually mean
to leave
uh I think the process was over a few
years
by the time I got to
around 16 17 years old I knew I was
going to leave when I was 18. I just had
to ride my time a bit
it was incredibly scary for me very very
frightening because you know we've been
told
the outside world was a dangerous place
the bad things happened especially to
people who turn their back on God
so you know you had all that fear of
being punished
by God and bad things happening to you
and then from a practical point of view
we really didn't have the knowledge just
to live in the outside world you know we
hadn't been brought up to open to you
know know how to open a bank account or
how do you get a job especially when
you've had no formal education you've
been homeschooled your whole life in a
very questionable uh
amount of Education was given to you
that was very strange and not really
adequate to to get any kind of a decent
job on the outside
um so you it kind of felt like you were
just thrown out there yeah you wouldn't
get any support Financial or practical
from the culture or your family
uh you were just set you know you want
to leave go
and you had to learn very quickly how to
survive on your own
I had met someone at that point so
luckily I had somewhere I could live in
the early days but the whole process was
extremely difficult and it was really
over a decade at least before I even
felt remotely like I was part of society
because you know it wasn't even just the
Practical things that I had to learn to
do from scratch
it was just the way I was for example
you know the way I talked I used terms
that were very strange to Outsiders
because they were cult lingo and cult
terms that we used so you always kind of
felt completely out of place like you
didn't belong and that was very
difficult psychologically and would you
say to people that you met after a
couple of years you know would you say
was it was the cult something that you
felt embarrassed and ashamed about that
you didn't want to talk to new people
about I was definitely yeah because I
think once or twice I had tried and I
saw the way people looked at me
differently after that
um
I think now maybe not so much but back
then
there was a perception that if you were
from a cult born or recruited into it
you were you know a strange person you
were someone who was screwed up and
someone who wasn't normal I think with
time now I've learned to accept that
there is a massive difference already
between being recruited and being born
into already there was no choice
um but secondly
um
I like to prove to people
that you can have a past like that and
be completely normal but certainly the
first years very quickly I understood it
was going to be a big secret I had to
keep so an old fake story
you know because people be like why do
you come from such a big family I'd be
like oh my parents are really Christian
and why did you grow up abroad my dad
worked for the embassies I kind of made
up this whole
fictional past that I'd use to try and
get away with the fact that I had a
weird accent despite being French and
you know just so many things just you
had to explain away
because you just couldn't tell the truth
obviously as I
got to a point later where I felt part
of society I then moved on to a big
stage of my healing which was writing my
book and I was as I was writing that
that's when I started to get a bit more
confident about
speaking up and realized you know this
is not my shame to carry absolutely not
I I had no choice in this and the fact
that I'm still live right now when so
many of my peers aren't
you know
that's something I should be proud of
and when you say that your peers aren't
because of what why are they not well a
lot of ex-members because you know in
the cold there wasn't just physical and
sexual abuse There Was You know you're
talking about entire childhood of
psychological and emotional abuse as
well and when you get out into the world
you know it's very very difficult to try
and become part of society when you've
grown up in such an alternative
lifestyle it's like being dunked on an
alien planet and you know and for a lot
of ex-members sadly a lot turn to
addictions a lot you know especially the
the first ones that left particularly
some of them had to go and get jobs as
you know strip teasers and things like
that for example because they just they
had no education they didn't know how to
make money
um
but a lot of people still did well
practically and with jobs and things but
then
had so much trauma from their past and
you know we were never talked about
things we never talked about things like
mental health in the cold we didn't we
feared psychologists rather than you
know seeing that they could be there to
help
um and a lot of us suffer with
depression with PTSD
um and I think back in the days
particularly there were very few
psychologists who were able to help cult
members they just didn't understand
um and sadly you know we've lost a lot
of
um X sgas so my peers to Suicide a lot
so we we estimate now there's a minimum
of a 150 probably closer to 200 and
possibly a lot more because when they
leave the coal often they'll you know go
and disperse and they never want to have
contact with another cult member again
so the true number I mean we've been
trying to keep some sort of record and
we know it's in the hundreds but and
it's definitely over a hundred
but it's impossible to say how many but
we still have suicides today we still
have every couple months every three
months we hear of another one
and in terms of that and the reasons for
it am I right in thinking that you've
you'd be you've formed a group haven't
you to try and bring some of these
people to justice is that right well
myself and several other xsgas uh we got
together and formed a group called the
cogtfi survivors so Cog for children of
God TFI for the family International
um and we decided you know we need we
need to do something now because it's
been so long they've been getting away
with this the cult still exists Karen
zerby's still out there there's not even
an arrest warrant out against her when
there is so much evidence against her
um that can be easily found online
there's so much evidence given against
her in testimony as well be it from
people speaking out to the media or even
affidavits that you know the FBI in
Interpol for example they've have many
many files on the cult they have many
many affidavits on the cult
and yet they've done nothing
absolutely nothing and she's just out
there living a free life
in hiding last reported was hiding
somewhere in Mexico but we really don't
know where she is but then you know
that's something that an Enterprise like
Interpol or the FBI they could find her
easily if they really wanted to but it's
a fact that they're not even looking
that outrageous a lot of other sex
members because we feel like you know
we've been speaking out for so long and
no one's doing anything and we're being
told they're are two big factors so it's
the international nature of the crime so
for example the man who abused me he was
a Filipino national who abused a French
national
in Thailand
so where do you even start
plus everyone used fake names in The
Cult so I had no idea who he was like
many people don't have the real identity
of their abuser I did find out who he
was I got a tip off
after I went public and my name came out
so
I knew exactly which city he lived in in
Philippines
that he was part of a church
that he had a young child and was
married I got recent photos of him as
well really and did you find his name as
well yes I did WOW but
all I could do was write to the Filipino
Justice organization and that one
nowhere of course
so what what's my next option nothing
and so many of us are in this same
position or there's issues with statute
of limitations which should not exist
for sex crimes that's a big thing we
talk about as well
um any crime that happened to a child
particularly there should be no limit on
when you can report it because you know
by the time you're ready emotionally to
do so
they just turn around and go well it's
too late
should have done that years ago but
we've had two very successful
convictions in the UK recently
against abusers not against the cult but
what we're saying as a group is
we need the leaders
to take responsibility now we need them
to be searched for by Interpol or by the
FBI
you know you're telling us there's an
issue with countries and time but that
wasn't an issue with Weinstein that
wasn't an issue with jizland Maxwell
that wasn't an issue with Epstein either
when the media is paying enough tension
attention to something Suddenly It's
possible to find these people and bring
them to court and that's what we want is
to raise enough media attraction
to get someone interested
in looking for Karen Zerby and making
her answer for her crimes
do you think that it's possible for
anyone to join a cult not as you know
not be born into one but any grown adult
do you think it takes a certain type of
personality to be able to be brainwashed
into something like that or do you think
it's possible for anyone to fall into
that
already I never use the term join occult
you're recruited okay they're
professional recruiters cults I think
absolutely anyone could be dragged into
one because they're they're so Adept at
changing as well they adapt with times
so for for example right now they're
estimated to be about 1 000 Cults who
are active in the UK
but they're not going to look like the
children of God or or anything like that
a lot of them now are through other
things that attract people they're
online communities yoga running groups
even I've heard of
um they pass under all sorts of
different more modern things that are
more attractive to people and using more
modern technology social media so that
they they really they adapt the way they
work all the time
and their front adapts all the time to
fit in with whatever is acceptable in
society so it really doesn't take much
to be pulled in I mean our cult you had
people who were highly educated with
phds just like you had drug addicts who
joined you had rich people you had
Fleetwood Macs guitarist Jeremy Spencer
who joined and was in for many years wow
yeah so yeah all walks of society I
think you just have to have that
combination of being at maybe a point in
your life where you're searching for
something or you may be a bit
dissatisfied you need a change or you
know maybe there needs to be that little
spark but as far as what kind of person
no I don't think there's any stereotype
and the cult still exists today as you
mentioned you know yeah how does it look
today in terms of an organization is it
still doing the big military style camps
or is it in smaller groups so they're
much smaller now I think there's a
couple thousand people and they call
themselves now an online Church
um but we don't really know we know
they're still active we know they're
active in many countries still but
they're so secretive about their
activities that we don't really know
though we did hear recently that they
were still occasionally recruiting
people so
that was interesting for an online
community
I guess my final question to you is as
someone who's lived a life that's really
quite different to most people you know
what's it taught you what's the lesson
that your life's taught you
predominantly to never give up
because if I give up I feel like the
cult wins hmm
um
and probably my view of humans in
general you know never to judge people
because I've seen
what trauma and pain does to people you
know
even years down the line later in life
you know even now there are a lot of
ex-members some of who I know personally
who who struggle
very much with addiction still multiple
addictions generally
who are constantly feeling suicidal and
it's
I guess that it's made me understand
just what actions can do to a child
and I think it's really important in
general to be very mindful of way you
speak to a child the way you act with a
child because the repercussions later
are you know it could have been an
experiment for them but what they did
was raise an entire generation of people
who who struggle every day just to stay
alive
because you know they have so much pain
in them
and if you could speak to anyone who is
listening to this that's in the position
you're in when you started to realize
something wasn't right
and probably had that fear of the
realization
what would you say to them
I would say don't be scared to make that
jump
is going to be the scariest thing you'll
ever do
but there are more and more people out
there who will help there's a lot more
awareness now of the impacts of Cults of
occult to bring your occult experience
there's a lot more associations out
there who are willing to help even
practically and and you know with
practical things to get you set up and
things
and a lot more therapists out there who
are trained now to deal with this kind
of trauma
so yeah I'd say uh it's scary but take
the leap and get out while you can don't
don't give them any more of your life or
your time
Natasha it's been amazing having you in
and it's a really really fascinating
story and you thank you so much for
being so open and telling it so well
um we really do wish you all the best
thanks for coming thank you very much
for having me
I looked to the side of the Qatar and
she had a jar
with things in it clitoris Libya Mojo
everything that she has cut previously
and then being sewn
whilst you are fully awake is one
experience that I don't think I will
ever forget